when congress finally got back to work
yesterday evening about 8 pm it took
many more hours to get through
republican objections to the electoral
vote
but in the small hours of the morning
vice president pence finally accepted
the results
it was the middle of the night declaring
president-elect biden the winner of the
2020 election
nancy cordes saw it all happen on
capitol hill
the chair declares the joint session
dissolved
it was the culmination of a day of chaos
capped by vice president mike pence
rejecting president trump's false claim
that he could overturn the electoral
college
he recorded president-elect joe biden's
win
just before 4 a.m joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
the senate will come to order that
concluded pence's duties presiding over
a joint session of congress both before
and after an hours-long siege of the
capitol
by president trump's supporters the
world will again witness
the resilience and strength of our
democracy
for even in the wake of unprecedented
violence and vandalism
at this capitol lawmakers on both sides
tried their best to seal president-elect
biden's win
on the day called for in the
constitution january
6 but they were thwarted by a violent
wave of protesters in the halls of
congress
and later by republicans in the house
and senate
missouri senator josh hawley and dozens
of house members
pushing to throw out the electoral votes
from pennsylvania there were defections
from the cause
georgia senator kelly lefler decided not
to challenge
her state's results a day after losing
her own bid for re-election
and i cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
of these electors a series of top
republicans condemned
not only the day's violence but the
president's role
in stoking it what happened here today
was an insurrection
incited by the president of the united
states some of the strongest rebukes of
the night came from
one of president trump's most loyal
defenders
i hate it then this way oh my god i hate
it
from my point of view he's been a
consequential president but today
first thing you'll see all i can say
is count me out enough is enough
many republicans were asked last night
whether
they felt any sense of responsibility
for stoking the sense of
anger and grievance among these
protesters by refusing for months to
acknowledge that president-elect biden
had won
or by pushing these unsubstantiated
claims
of election fraud tony some of those
republicans said
they felt no responsibility others
didn't answer and some
just blamed the president how did we get
here that is a question we'll be chewing
over in this show and for years to come
no doubt nancy cordes thank you very
much